trade talks turmoil tea tip hope or fear
that's our topic today on quad Riga
welcome negotiators from the US and
Europe are working around the clock
trying to finalize a new transatlantic
trade agreement they thought they were
working in secret until a large chunk of
the negotiating text found its way onto
the internet could that spell the end of
T tip the plant agreement is bringing
more and more people out onto the
streets in protest Europeans are worried
about consumer protection and
environmental standards especially after
Greenpeace leaked damaging information
from the ongoing talks investors and
companies are eager for a deal the
German Chancellor in the US president
both stand behind t tip saying it will
encourage economic growth and trade so
we'll teach hip really raise all boats
or will it benefit only wealthy
corporations and the elite that's what
we want to talk about with three experts
who are following t tips progress
carefully stormy Milner is the head of
the Department of external economic
policy at the Federation of German
industries BDI she says German industry
believes that t tip will give our
companies and our small and medium scale
enterprises in particular better access
to the US market however it's important
that T tip remain ambitious and
comprehensive we do not want t to light
monta leeming is editor of the opinion
page of debt ago Spiegel he says t tip
would most probably boost economies on
both sides of the Atlantic and
strengthen town transatlantic ties
European fears about decisively lower
food and environmental standards are
overblown and Stefan kook is the head of
green pieces political unit the NGO
behind last week's major leak he says
TTFN has to be stopped because in the
agreement consumer and environmental
protection are less important than
business interests
mr. Krug aren't business interests
pretty important for Europe at the
moment growth here is lagging
unemployment is drastically high in many
many countries can you really afford to
walk away from him and from an agreement
that would create the biggest free trade
zone in the world well that's upon
Europe to decide what we did is just
leaking the state of plate of
negotiations that has been dealt so far
completely behind closed doors even for
elected members of parliament they
couldn't just talk publicly about it so
we just we just opened the floor for a
public debate and if Europe decides to
whether to continue these talks or two
to skip them I wouldn't say that this is
the moment at this moment the moment
hasn't come but I think that's up to
Europe we just did a job off of making
clear what's what's at stake but clearly
Greenpeace is of the opinion that what
is that steak certainly does not justify
an agreement of the kind it's shaping up
well yes we are very quickly critical
towards T tip we think that this is a
kind of trade deal which we don't need I
mean there has been already a lot of
ongoing relationships between the US and
Europe in terms of economic trade we
don't think that as it is set up it can
really boost standard to the contrary it
will probably lower the stands we
already have in Europe and maybe also
some of the standards that are higher in
the u.s. so at the end we don't expect
very good things come out of this we're
going to take another look at the
standards but isn't slightly lower
standards but perhaps a justifiable
price to pay for getting more jobs I
don't think so no we we shouldn't lower
a consumer protection we shouldn't know
where environmental protection standards
this is something we have worked for and
very hardly worked over the last decades
to get this standard which is a very
high standard worldwide in Europe and I
don't think we should put it at risk
just because some corporates need a bit
more product miss another according to
classical free trade theory it only
brings prosperity for all if the gains
from opening markets are used to
compensate those who lose out
apps lose their jobs perhaps see their
wages fall in the face of stronger
competition that almost never happens
which is why trade has become a major
issue on both sides of the Atlantic what
is the experience that we have seen with
an agreement like NAFTA doesn't it
indicate that in fact those gains rarely
get redistributed now we actually don't
agree with that observation if you look
at the history of Germany or the
European Union we see very clearly that
trade has boosted economic growth it has
boosted income and is a very very
important foundation of our wealth and I
would say so also for the North American
area for Canada for the United States
and also for Mexico looking at Germany
every fourth job and this country
depends on trade in industry it's every
second job trade to GDP is 84 or almost
eighty-six percent that is massively
important for our wealth we depend on
global markets and open global markets
so we believe that tea service
definitely something we should not walk
away from especially looking at some of
our European neighbour countries who
have not experienced such sound growth
weights as we did in the past years but
really need a new growth impulse and we
would say that this is a chance we
should take but tita was not just
important because of economic growth and
jobs we believe that trade agreements
are much more today than just about
opening markets it is about how we want
to trade with each others it's about
global rules Willie so let's come back
to that in just a moment so we've got
one con voice we've got a pro voicemail
to let me you can be the tiebreaker here
you said in your opening statement you
thought T tip would probably boost the
US and European economies so a somewhat
conditional statement there the fact is
the u.s. is already Germany's greatest
trading partner largest trading partner
tariffs duties already pretty low so
really do you think the gains would
justify the risks I'm not sure about the
risks but the gains is I mean if if
trees who have already agreements on
trade and business don't need another
agreements that we don't need a European
Union we had agreements before between
germany and france between germany and
spain between other countries that we
still think the european union forming a
huge unity of of common trade and common
legal rules about the tray is a good
idea so I think that is in principle a
good idea the gains is is dependent on
if we have tita blight a very small
agreement or the original replant teetav
which is now a big question but let me
make two two more points one is European
skepticism this skepticism not European
it's German Germany Austria and
Luxembourg all other 25 member states of
the European Union have a majority 40
tip next point is secrecy does
Greenpeace have if you're discussing
about what to do next with a spectacular
action doing that in public no our
agreements on the climate summit in
Paris done and open and the Russians and
Chinese saying what kind of points they
want to make no it's not even made it
protocol after that which is done with T
tip there's a to coalition parties have
open discussions about how they form a
killer coalition and make an agreement
know all this is made behind closed
doors and to make is the secrecy the top
critical point about tea tip I think
it's over I think I heard you saying
under breath sotto voce that you don't
entirely agree in terms of the
geographical distribution of opposition
yes I mean first of all let me just at
one point a growth so far is a promise
of T tube that hasn't been really
delivered the European Commission itself
now says that the growth rate will be
0.5 percent over the overtime period of
10 years so it's practically nothing so
that's that's on growth on the terms of
transparency nobody is expecting
politicians sitting at the market place
in Brussels and discussing it publicly I
followed the climate negotiations very
closely and I can tell you they are much
more transparent than TTP has ever been
even now because the European Commission
has made some changes over
they have now set up reading rooms they
say this is the most transparency they
have ever provided on ongoing diplomatic
negotiations well sorry but a reading
room where a member of parliament can
enter only under under guidance is not
allowed to take copies as not the the
allowance to take an expert with them to
understand these very complicated text
and should not talk about anybody
afterwards has to sign a paper on this
this is probably not the height stage of
it let me ask you again so that means
you have official Russian and Chinese
documents saying with with what kind of
points they are going into climate
negotiations of course of course you
know that position wise beforehand you
can if you know them that's another
point you have an official chinese
docking of course i can even participate
in negotiations as an observer you're
not allowed to contribute to the
discussion but you can follow the
negotiations point by point so that's a
completely different scene of
transparency and I don't understand
really why a trade deal needs this type
of complete secretness i mean i
perfectly understand that there has been
confidence some are between the between
the parties negotiating but it's no sign
of transparency if the public is
completely out of the play let's come
back in just a moment to the geographic
issue and get starving milner to answer
to that because again she's shaking her
head now clearly you don't quite agree
either on the point about growth or the
point about transparency well she both
but we got to the approval ratings
there's a you will borrow meet her poor
they do it twice a year and the last one
in November showed pretty clearly that
in for Europe as a whole the support
weight is still pretty high the majority
of European support t-tube and it's um
it's actually four countries where the
majority is against heater it's those
and now also slovenia if i'm not
mistaken but it's pretty mean the debate
we are having here in germany it's
pretty specific and what I do that later
it says he that we do have a little
report about that but give us your view
on the growth point that was just made
and also on the point about Paris we
believe that although we already trade a
lot with the United States they are
still
a lot of gain we could could utilize by
getting rid of still existing trade
barriers you said that tariffs are
already pretty low but taking into
account how much we trade with each
other even those low trade barriers will
lead to quite a bit of an impact and on
the other hand there are tons of
technical barriers to trade and I'm not
talking about those which are consumer
standards or environmental centers but
technical barriers to trade like a
machine is to be normed a standard where
we could cooperate mare and that also
promises performance is really quite a
bit on the issue of transparency I think
it is I mean transparency is really
vital for the legitimacy of the
negotiations and we always have
supported that the negotiation mandate
should be public the proposal should be
public but we also believe there needs
to be a room for negotiators to get
together and negotiate i mean i'm pretty
sure that you also wouldn't like us to
be and the room was a negotiators and
wheezing in there next as we would like
you to view there so i think there needs
to be a room of protection for them what
do you say to the charges that okay
there may be some opposition in other
european countries but it's absolutely
strongest here in germany it's brought
tens of thousands of people out onto the
streets why is that well there's a
strong consumer and environmental
movement in germany germany
environmental policy has a very high
respect in in in the public debate but i
think it's a growing it's a prone
skepticism all over europe now you see
the reactions in France for example I
mean Chancellor Merkel didn't say the
same thing then that said president
alone so I think there is a much much
stronger opposition now growing I think
well of course specifically in Germany
are very sensitive if a vinyl standards
are put it's at risk and also consumer
protection this these are very important
issues and as far as ttp stands it now
shows that in in the regularity
cooperation which is planned these
tenets are put at stake let's take a
look at some of the things that are
worrying German consumers
many Germans have fears about tea tip
they're scared in the future they'll
have to eat chlorinated chickens or GM
corn to symbols for what many view as
lower consumer safety standards in the
US others are worried about social
dumping that good jobs in Germany with
social benefits will be replaced by more
precarious ones with longer hours and
lower wages some are afraid of
environmental impacts that fracking a
highly controversial method for
obtaining oil and natural gas will be
extended or that high standards in the
area of renewable energy could be viewed
by the US as a trade barrier then there
are fears involving culture the u.s. is
against book price fixing and film
subsidies it's negotiators say
subventions and cultural fields distort
competition so where the fears justified
will t tip bring Europe more problems
than solutions so multi looming is this
just another case of German angst or is
there more to it than that there is more
to it but there is angst into that as
well I would say there is it the
perception of T tip-in in Germany in it
combines with the perception of America
in general we have the greedy companies
greedy lawyers who just wait for for
class action to be taken we have low
environmental and food standards and I
think history and reality speaks the
opposite is true if we look for for
example the photog scandal or the FIFA
scandal or all which is which is brought
up it's in the United States and we have
the the mad and cow disease in Europe
it's the united states that actually
could bring these can destroy these
candles up and have lower you have have
higher standards in indian car
manufacturers and many thank you to make
that point if you go to a fruit and
vegetable shop they all wear plastic
gloves try to find out in germany it
seems that many Americans actually
believe their own standards are higher
than not the European ones you lived in
the US you were bureau chief there for
your paper for I think five years what's
your impression of the standards there
the standards are quite high the
standards are quite high and and the
punishment for companies to violate
these tenders is even higher I mean if
you have VPX on petrol scandal and
there's it they pay
billions in damage payment for that the
Volkswagen scandal they will pay
billions for that because the punishment
is really high if you violate these
standards so this is one point the other
point is why is it that in Germany it
sits right Germans are very high
expectations to word food and and and
and ecological standards but I think
something else happened in the past and
was the NSA the National Security Agency
scandal and they felt violated by the
Americans and they feel they need some
kind of revenge because they think it's
more on the interest of the Americans
than the Europeans to have this kind of
deal so this is this kind of perception
and in place into that perception of tea
tip that is saying know if we say no we
give the American we tell the Americans
a lesson or something like this so I
think it's no purpose why the extreme
left and right wings are closing ranks
in this industry so the standards issue
stephannie klug let's start with chicken
the US chicken coated with chlorine
European chicken often injected with
antibiotics is that so much better why
shouldn't consumers be permitted to
choose whether they like their chicken
poisoned by chlorine or poisoning well
that's a choice between poisons you're
right but well it's not about being
against America or get being against any
anything that is coming from there I
mean I may remind you that Winkies was
founded by Americans and Canadians so
it's not in our DNA to be to be against
America and even some higher summer
standards are higher in the US let's
take the nitrogen oxide emissions for
example we would be happy to have them
in Germany but the problem is what
corporates are doing peed in America obd
Europe it's all about the same the same
problem and the problem is simply that
if an industrialized agriculture are
completely industrial agriculture with
GMO food with hormone treated meat maybe
some chicken and chlorine maybe this is
not the biggest problem but if this type
and this system of Agriculture is taking
over then we have a huge problem here
because we have a very different
agriculture we have a very small scale
of culture every culture at the same
time we have big corporates but also
small regional producers and the
standards that are in Europe now
valuable especially the ecological
standards
they are quite higher and much tougher
than they are on the u.s. so we should
keep them higher standards of course
mean higher costs the system you are
advocating is in many ways a
paternalistic system not all consumers
necessarily can and want to pay more for
their food isn't it somewhat
presumptuous to say that those of lower
income shouldn't have the right to
choose cheaper food that is perhaps not
quite at that same level standard why we
don't say that people can do that today
we don't need more imports from the u.s.
to to fulfill that we don't say that
everybody now has to buy eco food and no
no other food would be allowed but what
we say is that the industrial
agriculture has a lot of flaws it has a
disastrous impact on the environment it
is the number one problem in terms of
biodiversity in terms of soil pollution
in terms of water pollution we all know
that so we should try to strive to get a
better agriculture and this is not
especially the agricultural model that
is used in the US which is a large-scale
industrial model we should we should
strive to two other models and I don't
think that TT will bring any improvement
here Tommy Millner there are suggestions
at times that tea tip would replace
European social market capitalism with
something more like the u.s. casino
capitalist model putting corporations in
the driver's seat as Greenpeace said
when it leaked these documents are you
concerned about that is there an element
of truth to that we don't think so first
of all I wanted to say something on the
agricultural market and the United
States I don't think it is quite correct
to say that it's only industrial
agriculture which the US has it has a
huge market for small and medium-sized
farms and also organic farming the
organic farming market in the u.s. is
bigger than our market and the criteria
for organic farming is are just as high
as here they're even stricter with
regard to the use of antibiotics in the
meat production so I think this painting
black and white that is something we
really shouldn't do the US has higher
standards in some areas we have higher
standards and others and the question is
now is will t tab lead to a lower
standard
the lower common denominator and we
don't believe so because most of our
consumer protection standards
environmental standards are European
laws and our lawmakers the European
Parliament why should they ever ever
agree to a t-tube which is going to take
away what they have fought for in higher
standards on the other side of the
Atlantic the US Congress has fought and
also President Obama has fought for
higher standards through the
Environmental Protection Agency for
example why ever should he agree on a
lowest denominator and and lower
standards I just don't see that not in a
democratic system so let me let me just
take us into the future the very short
term future the T tip negotiations are
now moving into what the negotiators
called the end game the rush is on to
get the agreement settled by this summer
the big question is can the negotiators
overcome one particularly thorny issue
related to commercial arbitration
commissions let's take a look for four
years the international center for the
settlement of investment disputes has
been arbitrating an explosive case
Swedish energy giant button file is
suing Germany the company says it will
lose money because the country decided
in 2011 to phase out nuclear energy
forcing button fire to take some nuclear
reactors offline early the firm says
it's been treated unjustly and that
earlier investments are now worthless
it's demanding 4.7 billion euros and
reparations the case is heightened fears
that ft tip comes into force foreign
companies that operate in Germany could
have national laws overruled by the
court at the World Bank in Washington do
such courts pose a threat to national
sovereignty
what do you think multi lemming threat
to national sovereignty and if so can a
compromise be found I don't think I
general that courts posit posit threat
and democracies because calls courts are
driven by the commercial shy know what I
had driven by the rule of law they have
lost they follow up and they need to see
if they were obliged to in the last 30
years I think there were 17 cases that
the Americans brought a coat like that
so I don't think that then and you can
you can give these cords regulations
that minimize the risks that is with the
just seen Stefan crook the EU Commission
has made a counter proposal for an EU
trade corridor free eu-us trade court
essentially that would be a state entity
could Greenpeace live with that is that
a compromise that you'd like to see
happen well we don't see it as a
compromise we always hear as a kind of
cosmetic attempt to get T tip dealt out
because the simple fact is that it also
would create a justice system of court
and justice in parallel to the already
existing democratically legitimized
system we don't need that between two
very developed states or groups of
states if you do an investment in a
country that has a very bad governance I
don't know very developing country still
with corruption with many problems on
the place i understand that investors
want to have an assurance want to have
some kind of rules and possibilities to
to to make lawsuits against the
government but this is not necessary
between the US and europe it we have a
perfectly developed system of justice we
don't need private arbitrary is to to do
the job and then having no no
possibility for ordinary people and
ordinary courts to to to claim that that
decision star be milder there have been
us suggestions to just sideline the
issue and go with a leaner version of t
tip consensus where it can be found you
say you don't want to tip light why not
because today trade is not just about
shipping goods from one one country to
another trade has become very different
from twenty thirty
years ago it is about trading services
it is about digital to Trey has
something to do with data it is trade
has become a very different animal so to
say and for this we also need you new
rules rules which we don't have yet it
would be great to have these through the
WTO the World Trade Organization but
since the Doha round since 2001 has not
delivered these rules we need to see how
we can set those wolves with partners
who are very close to us with regard to
the norms and values we have so we view
and t tip as a chance to shape these
rules and by the way investment
protection as one of these areas where
this could really be a good case so very
briefly if you would the window of
opportunity is closing both for this
show and 40 tip the negotiators want to
get it done by summer because after
Obama's term ends there may not be any
pro-trade person in the White House
montalais me will it happen sixty
percent yes I would say don't
underestimate the resistance in Europe
but don't underst and they see made the
ambitions of Obama in his last month's
Stefan cooked you see it going through I
don't think so to be honest and I hope
that also the Canadian European trade
agreement does not see the light of day
because it's a teacher pin in TT of
light set aside stormy Milner it will be
tricky but for as the content was more
important than time we want to teach
right not a teat of light thanks very
much to all of you for being with us
today and thanks to all of you out there
for tuning in see you soon
you